Dude, I don't really think we could win
this thing. What? This is kind of money
I was really excited about this. Whoa.
dude we're in trouble
these are insane no
this is insane
we made an electric motor with nothing
but our hands and our minds that's
awesome
they got lasers okay but that one got
like smoke this got like lasers and
smoke. Like how?
That is pretty cool
Welp, see you tomorrow.
This is not good for us. Wait a minute
I have an idea. Here, hold that.
careful dad okay
Agent Thomas.
Agent Thomas, is Peter Parker spider-man yeah I
know look I'm at my school science fair
I desperately need the greatest electric
motor of all time can you please just
give me access to 2025? Kid, 2025 is not
a plaything. No, I know that.
I know that. This is really important.
Okay fine, I'll do a swing by your son's
birthday party. Fine.
Not one scratch though thank you. Hey um
can you stall for me? Just stall Ned!
I only have like three minutes of small
talk, max.
Ohh! Hurry Peter!
Hope this works
Afternoon Mr. Lee! Tell us about your
project. Peter and I worked really hard
on it
it's our brain baby
We begin in 1820
when physicists... Hey Ned!
why don't we
show them our example? Yes!
So our first model is our own self built
motor terrific with 10 kilowatts of
power
The electric motor in this car is
similar to our motor except it has a
steering wheel and these really cool
touchscreen screens and there's also
seat heaters
yes Ned.
Huh what's the range on this
thing far wide and wide.
It's far and wide yeah oh can you
gentlemen thank you very compelling
Second place we have an electric sports
car dude first place was a potato arc
reactor yeah.
Hey everybody its Charlie
there's a whole bunch of spider-man
stuff going on we got a bunch of new
footage we have Kevin Feige talking
about venom crossover movies so we'll
break it all down the footage is them
just doing a funny outie integration
just like they did the driving exam from
spider-man homecoming if you remember
spider-man was taking his driver's test
they did it as an Audi ad because Audi
pays Disney millions and millions of
dollars for ad integrations and they
give them access to a bunch of Audi cars
to either blow up or use in their movies
or do whatever they want to with that's
why every time you see someone driving a
car during say like an Avengers movie
like Iron Man when he drove the new eat
Ron or during spider-man homecoming or
now spider-man far from home everybody
always drives an Audi if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the Marvel videos there's
going to be so much stuff happening in the
next couple of weeks including that
extended cut of Avengers endgame with
that new post-credit scene but we're
doing a giveaway for IMAX gift
certificates all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave in Avengers
or Spider Man comments on the video
we'll talk about the footage first then
we'll talk about the venom crossover
movie the whole premise here is that
they're having a special science fair at
their special magnet school Midtown High
within the Marvel Cinematic Universe is
a magnet school for science and
technology so even though they only
briefly addressed it during spider-man
homecoming all the kids here actually
had to be really smart just to get in
the front door when they were
refreshments so even Natalie's here is
supposed to be a pretty smart kid they
had that scene during spider-man
homecoming where he's helping Peter hack
the stark tech suit so he does know a
couple of things but most of the time
the movies just kind of brush over this
stuff the way they brush over Iron Man
solving time-travel like remember during
avengers endgame oh i think i solved
time travel in the span of a couple of
nights and they have all those montages
of peter making different versions of
his webbing there's a little bit of that
going on during the movie too peter
making his own new suit using Iron Man's
special printer on the back of the jet
even though it gets blown up later in
the film so when we get to spider-man 3
he'll have to make his next using some
other technology but there were a lot of
comments about that back during
spider-man homecoming like how come
Peter isn't making his own suit well
they're just kind of working up to that
because he was a sophomore in high
school now he's a junior and spider-man
far from home
then during the course of spider-man 3
presumably he'll be a senior getting
ready to graduate or it'll be taking
place around his graduation you could
see how they might tie that in with the
themes of whatever the villains are
doing during spider-man 3 like he's
graduating from lesser problems to much
bigger problems so we could talk about
spider-man 3 stuff after spider-man far
from home comes out little weird that
they're keeping all these special shield
cars stashed all over Queens then the
big joke of them rolling up in the
e-tron is still only winning second
place because some kid made an arc
reactor with a potato there's a bit of a
riff on the joke from Iron Man 1 where
Obadiah Stane goes ham on one of his
engineers because they can't figure out
how to make arc reactor technology as
efficiently as Iron Man did inside a
cave honestly it's impossible but the
big spider-man vs. venom crossover movie
the Kevin Feige was talking about this
week they were doing the press junkets
for spider-man far from home of course
people were asking Kevin Feige about the
future of spider-man would he ever
crossover with venom what's going on
with live-action spider-verse is that
ever going to be a thing as per usual
Kevin Feige said a lot without really
saying a whole lot
so his quote was I think that's probably
upto sony sony has both those characters
it has venom in their world I don't know
what their plans are for another venom
or if they're doing that but it seems
likely at some point so you read between
the lines there's actually a lot of good
news here too that implies with the
future of spider-man inside the MCU is
as well because people are wondering if
Marvel is going to resign their sharing
arrangement with Sony because that ends
with spider-man far from home so if Sony
really wanted to be dicks about it they
could take Tom Hollands spider-man
character in not reassigned the sharing
arrangement and just bring him into
their venom burst and just make as many
spider-man movies as they want until
people get tired of it but because of
what Kevin Feige says and all these
movies are pushing for sequels
spider-man far from home obviously
pushing for the sequel spider-man 3 it
means that venom isn't going to be in
spider-man 3 in venom will probably not
come into the Marvel Cinematic Universe
at all normally you would think that
that's a bummer but the
good thing about that news is it means
that Sony is just going to take Tom Holland
and put him in the venom verse for
whatever venom vs. spider-man movie that
they do then when we get to spider-man 3
spider-man will be back in the MCU so
it'll be more like Tom Holland crossing
the multiverse rather than venom
crossing the multiverse they're making
the venom sequel right now but that's
really just venom versus carnage I don't
expect him to try an actual venom vs.
spider-man movie or venom and spider-man
teaming up against carnage so we get to
say like venom three or even further
beyond that there's going to be carnage
cleanest way possible to explain it is
that you just have spider-man wake up
one day some rift in the multiverse he
winds up in the venom verse otherwise if
you were to try to do it the Spider Man
into the spider verse way where you have
an evil scientist that's trying to break
into the multiverse you have a whole
crazy subplot to set up and this isn't
the cartoon universe if you remember the
90s animated cartoon the way that
spider-man winds up falling into the
multiverse or the spider verse as you
call it is is that Madame web shows up
and brings him into the spider verse so
because we just haven't quite got there
in the MCU characters like Madame web
they just show up out of the multiverse
and say hey you know what I can do all
these things I have crazy powers I'm
just going to join you and put you on this
other planet for a brief period just for
the duration of this movie then I'll
bring you back it's just way too crazy
to explain stuff like that so if you
remember the whole Mysterio story during
spider-man far from home is that the
snaps caused rips in the space-time
continuum leaving tears in the
multiverse allowing things to spill into
our universe regardless of what Mysterio
is lying about during the movie Sony can
totally use that as a plot point for how
spider-man accidentally winds up inside
the venom verse the reason why I think
that that would work better for a
maximum carnage movie is just because
you can do way crazier things and Sony
can sort of build up to a big crossover
in its universe like it could bring
Morbius into that movie too if it was if
the Morbius movie is successful next
year but they do their own smaller
version of what you would consider
infinity war and it just becomes this
big carnage event carnage super popular
character really easy slam-dunk as long
as they nail the script
then when it's all over you just bring
spider-man back to the MCU and he just
has another crazy field trip
quote-unquote that he can tell his
friends about you guys will never
believe what just happened last summer I
got pulled into this other universe
there was a black Scindia version of me
and then after their spider-man venom
crossover they have a really easy way of
explaining how venom can get the
spider-man symbol on his chest because
during the crossover they defeat carnage
together the symbiote and Eddie Brock
are inspired by spider-man and they want
to be like him so that's when they make
the white spider-man symbol on Venom's
costume you want to put Tom Holland in
the symbiote that's also the same way to
do it too you do it when he's crossed
over into the venom verse he temporarily
gets it but then manages to get it off
it goes back to Eddie Brock by the end
of the film and the spider-man comes
back without the symbiote because I
don't think that they would do symbiote
in the MCU if they're not going to do venom
in the MCU like Kevin Feige is implying
when they were developing Avengers
infinity war and looking at different
versions of the costume to give Tom Hall
and spider-man especially the iron
spider they had a couple different
concepts for what that would look like
one of them was a comic book accurate
iron spider and that's actually in the
spider-man far from home trailer when he
pulls up this readout display this is
comic book accurate iron spider here it
was also a black variant of that
obviously they wound up going with a
more red blue version of the iron spider
suit to make it look a little bit closer
to his stark tech suit colors I'll do a
separate video about live-action spider
verse because that's a little bit more
complicated and I think it'll take a lot
longer than say a venom vs. spider-man
crossover so it's a really easy
slam-dunk it's just going to take a while
as we get there so if the venom sequel
is supposed to come next October at
about two years to that for the earliest
that you could possibly see a spider-man
vs. venom crossover so we're talking
2023 there'll be a bunch of spider-man
stuff happening next week I'll do videos
for leave your requests in the comments
below
obviously there's all the Avengers
endgame rerelease and the extra
post-credit scenes no worries about that
I'll name a new giveaway winner when I
post new Marvel but click here for my
non-spoilery spider-man far from home
review and click here to learn about
that brand new Avengers endgame post
credits scene thank
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight!